what up reject nation welcome to the
real rejects youtube channel my name is
sally you can call me salamander if you
want to but uh only if you subscribe so
those are the rules it's free go ahead
and hit that subscribe button why
wouldn't you because then we can be on a
nickname basis you know what i mean you
can follow me at sally lamonico on
instagram or my own youtube channel
which is
you guessed it sally lamonico i am doing
a marvel movie marathon on this channel
i'm super excited about it we are still
on phase one so this video is going to
be me watching thor so if you are new to
the channel or if you haven't seen any
of my previous videos you can go ahead
and check them out i have watched iron
man i've watched the hulk iron man 2. so
yeah you can keep up with me if you
click that notification bell so that you
know when my next reaction is up we will
be going in order and if you're enjoying
this series you can watch the full movie
with me you can sit down grab a bucket
of popcorn watch the whole entire
two-ish hours of these movies if you go
to the real rejects patreon that's
patreon.com the real rejects greg and
john have a bunch of other cool on there
if you want to check them out full movie
reactions and full tv show reactions
actually so there's a lot of good stuff
on there definitely check it out if you
are curious also if at any point you
enjoy this reaction please give it a
like it really does help the algorithm
and you know it is free you know to do
so why not quick shout out to prepper
for editing together the highlights of
this video we really appreciate you here
on the real reject so thank you so much
from the bottom of our hearts and now it
is time to watch
full
oh that's not cringy it's probably
cringy
i thought you said it was a subtle
i'm with her on that one
imagine hitting a hot guy with your car
from space from a realm of cold and
darkness came the frost giants
the cold never bothered me anyway
it's like elsa
couldn't he just ice all of them
our armies drove the frost giants back
into the heart of their own world
impressive last great war ended
we withdrew from the other worlds and
returned home
asgard
[Music]
it's like the upside down but instead of
hell it's heaven
i'm getting ribbon doll vibes from lord
of the rings the frost giants still live
when i'm king
i'll hunt the monsters down and slay
them all a wise king
never seeks out war
do you swear
to cast aside all selfish ambition and
to pledge yourself only to the good of
the realm i swear
a man that's not selfish
to proclaim you
frost giants
how did they get through
yeah
they broke into the weapons vault
if the frost giants had stolen even one
of these relics they didn't well i want
to know why
his face
thinking only as a warrior this was an
act of war
but a few doomed to fail look how far
they got we will find the breach in our
defenses and it will be sealed as king
of asgard but you're not king
listen to your father
his facial expressions kill me i think
you're right
if they found a way to penetrate
asgard's defenses once who's to say they
won't try again next time with an army
we're going to yodenheim
[Music]
man if disney made a whole
land that looked like asgard
that would be sick i would go
heimdall may we pause
never
as an enemy slipped my watch until this
day
i wish to know how that happened
and you trust him why
if your return threatens the safety of
asgard by foster will remain closed
i have no plans to die today
i thought they just like hit the ground
hard
they landed nicely how did your people
get into asgard the house of odin
is full of traitors stop and think look
around you we're outnumbered know your
place brother
oh
bro
go now
while i still allow it
run back home little princess
please make it a challenge for me dude
shut up
because they will
oh my god
nada
oh my god
we must go
[Music]
see now you're just gonna piss them all
off
ah
[Music]
he could kill his friends doing that oh
my god
[Applause]
uh
oh god
that's a way to do it
forgotten everything i taught you
the old ways are done you'd stand giving
speeches while asgard falls you're out
of vain
greedy
cruel boy you are an old man and a fool
you're gonna regret saying that you are
unworthy
of these realms
you're unworthy
he's like humble yourself
i now take from you
your power
the name of my father
[Music]
oh he's straight banishing him
whosoever holds of this hammer
if he be worthy she'll possess the power
of thought
he's about to get a slice of humble pie
or a car what realm is this
alpheim dornheim new mexico
you death threatened me thor was so
punier
hi
just taking a little blood how dare you
attack the son of god
[Music]
bro
oh my god chill
you're no match for the mighty
[Music]
they should have that at disneyland
right by the sword and the stone that
would be cool
well our data can't tell us what it was
like to be inside that event and he can
so we're gonna find him
okay i'm gonna look all over new mexico
right
exactly
[Laughter]
i love it
here comes the government
per usual
they're gonna take the beer and run you
must go to the old father and convince
him to change his mind and if i do then
what he's arrogant he's reckless he's
dangerous you saw how he was today
is that what asgard needs from his
i mean he's kind of right
what am i
you're my son
i'm
blue in the aftermath of the battle i
went into the temple
and i found a baby
left to die
alfie's son
you took me for a purpose
what was it
you know it all makes sense now why you
favored thor all these years because no
matter how much you claim to love me
you're gonna have a frost giant sitting
on the throne of asgard
he just died
just drink i like it i know it's great
right no though
asked nicely i meant no disrespect all
right well no more smashing
deal
i have my wood the way he looked her up
and down like that
nobody could lift it
they said it was radioactive i had my
hands all over it which way
50 miles west of here
we need to appropriate your records and
all your atmospheric data by appropriate
do you mean steel
i'm on the verge of understanding
something extraordinary hey hey
thank you for cooperation
that sucks
father has fallen into the odin sleep
you can bring your urgent matter to me
your king
the
thursday thor's day
you think me strange yeah i do
good stranger bad stranger
i'm not quite sure yet
she won't hit somebody else
but who are you
really
she's not looking at the road at all
look what's down there you think you're
just gonna walk in grab our stuff and
walk out no
i'm gonna fly out
oh almost took off his shirt
[Music]
nice
last chance wait
i want to see this
[Music]
hmm
no
some of the most highly trained
professionals in the world look like a
bunch of minimum wage mall cops
don't go anywhere
loki
hmm
tell me is it jodenheim
let me explain to father father is dead
the threat of a new war
it was too much for him to bear
freaking liar
the burden of the throne has fallen to
me now
burden the truce with the otonheim is
conditional upon your exile
couldn't we find a way your mother
has forbidden
your return
this is goodbye brother
i'm so sorry
[Music]
hello [ __ ]
he was distraught when he found out that
you're taking all of our research
that was
years of his life gone that still
doesn't explain how he managed to tear
through our security
steroids
he's a bit of a fitness nut
it's gonna be all right i'm taking you
home now
nice dr selvik
just keep him away from the bars
if they knew he was lying why'd they let
him go where are we going
let's get a drink yes father okay there
we go
i don't know if you're delusional or
if you're pulling some kind of con i
don't care
just care about her
i've seen the way she looks at you
classic line
lead you into odin's chambers and you
can slay him where he lies
i
accept
oh my god is he okay
he's fine no engine at all
oh i still don't think you're the god of
thunder
what you ought to be
bromance
it was all i could get back
i'm sorry it's not as much as i promised
no no this is great this is
i don't have to start from scratch now
thank you
that's cute
you must finish what you started why
because you're right
yeah look
well i come from a place where they're
one in the same thing
she's in live
with a god
we must find thor
it's treason to help with treason
suicide
thor would do the same for us
you would defy the commands of loki our
king
break every oath you have taken as
warriors and commit treason to bring
thor back yes
not too subtle
is it you won't be able to convince the
scientific community of any of it not
without hard evidence
found you
yeah
you know i can't go well
my father is
dead because of me
i must remain in exile your father still
lives
i say for your act of treason you are
relieved of your duties as gatekeeper
and no longer citizen of asgard and i
need no longer obey you
[Music]
is that one of starks
yourself
[Music]
yeah try out running that
keep it distracted
oh no
oh
yes
[Music]
no i will die her warrior's death
stories will be told to this day
live
and tell those stories yourself hmm
that's a good line
we must return to asgard you have to
stop loki what about you
do not worry my friends i have a plan
didn't he just destroy the 7-eleven and
it's right there
i am truly sorry
but these people are innocent
oh no
i broke his neck
[Music]
at least you didn't get the liquor store
yes
king
god
literally
donald
i don't think you've been completely
honest with me know this son of cole son
of core
you stay forward you can count me as
your ally if
you return the items you have taken from
jane stolen
[Music]
[Applause]
give you my word
i will return for you
yes
your death came
at the end
of laffy
oh
and your death came by the son of odin
i swear to you mother
that they will pay for what they've done
today
loki
oh no
why have you done this
to prove to father that i am a worthy
son
i would have destroyed that race of
monsters you can't kill an entire race
what is this new found love for the
frost giants
hmm
forgive me
oh wow
dang he got there fast
i should have done it
for you
for all of us
no loki
[Music]
mic drop
i'm out
it's gone
this is how every woman feels when a guy
ghosts her
feel you
can you see her
yes
how is she
she searches for you
hmm
that's cute
[Music]
it's over
again i'm an idiot i did not watch the
end credits scene to thor because i'm
just like i'm a little out of the loop
you know i'm going to watch the end
credits scene to thor
now in a different outfit
hopefully it blows my mind
thor will return to the avengers yas
legend tells us one thing history
another
but every now and then we find something
that belongs to both
uh
what is it power doctor
if we can figure out how to tap it
maybe unlimited power
loki what are you doing boy well i guess
that's worth a look
well i guess that's worth a look
no
[Music]
loki pretended to be bill nye okay yeah
that was worth me going back wow what a
little snake he's a little snake but
he's still hot it's confusing so okay
that that seems like a great setup to
the avengers
for sure
and
captain america because doesn't that
little box thingy show up in captain
america anyway it's like the tesseract
right is that what it's called little
tessie i wish i had seen that before
watching captain america but i am about
to watch the avengers so all right i
liked it i enjoyed it we got a little
bit of low-key in there low-key low-key
you know
think what's next is my uh review of the
movie so enjoy that
so that was thor
i
really enjoyed this movie
my mom has been obsessed with this movie
like i remember when it first came out
she watched it all the time and i got
sick of seeing it on her tv i was like i
don't get it um
but i guess i never really paid much
attention to it until now and now i
understand why she always says i need a
horse
great line
i noticed there's a lot of similarities
between the lion king and this movie
actually and i love the lion king that's
just such a classic story loki obviously
reminded me of scar
and thor reminded me of simba even down
to like him dangling on the cliff and
more specifically when loki was
lying to him about how it was thor's
fault that his dad got killed and i
remember scar blamed simba for killing
his father and yeah there were
definitely a lot of similarities but i
still really enjoyed the dynamic of both
of them in this movie it was very unique
in terms of the acting and kind of how
they both still love each other through
this because you can see both sides
clearly and where they're both coming
from i feel like yeah loki is set up to
be a villain but you can kind of
understand why
he feels the way that he feels and why
he does the things that he does so i
really enjoyed that aspect like he's a
great villain in that regard i also just
really love fish out of water stories
they're so funny there's always so much
room for comedy and fish out of water
movies so thor being in new mexico
instead of you know being an asgard in
another realm
was really funny just to see him
interact with americans and their ways
of life versus where he's from it's just
it was really funny there was a a lot of
great comedic moments in this movie that
i enjoyed i really really like the
script because i would say in comparison
to some movies i've seen especially
superhero movies a lot of times just to
create more conflict i feel like a lot
of characters make dumb
you know decisions and i feel like with
this one a lot of times every decision
each character made specifically the
characters that are from new mexico
i got it like that a lot of it made
science and a lot of it i felt was
realistic in a sense of what they would
actually be doing and what they would
actually be trying to achieve and how
they go about it the fact that it all
kind of took place in one little spot
too and not like oh we have to save the
whole world like it was just
this intimate sort of story in this
small town i think also grounded it made
it more realistic in a sense obviously
the story
of him losing everything losing his
power losing the one thing that i feel
like defined him it's a classic
story for a superhero movie to lose the
power lose the suit or lose something
that makes them feel like that's what
defines them and so even though it's
been done a lot i still enjoyed the way
that this movie
uh handled it because
i don't think it was as dramatic as some
other movies make it and so it was still
definitely fun and thor definitely
didn't lose
his uh tenacity and his personality and
of course he changes in the beginning
he's super pompous
and arrogant and then by the end he's
very kind but still strong which is
great
i also just really loved the
cinematography in this movie there were
a lot of really really great shots
specifically standing out to me is the
scene where thor tries to take his
hammer out of the ground and colson's
standing there watching him with the
rain
and he obviously didn't do it and then
his sadness of not being able to pick up
his hammer that doesn't sound as sad
when i say it
but out of context
i don't know that whole scene was shot
beautifully and there were so many shots
i could tell
there's a term for it i went to film
school i'm blanking right now but where
is it like a dirty shot or something no
what is it it's like a term for it where
basically the angles are off uh
dutch angle and that kind of always
indicates that
there's something dangerous going on or
something uneasy about the situation i
noticed that a lot i just noticed the
composition and the movie just being
beautiful and
really enjoying it i also just love that
very human moment where he's like let's
go to a bar because i remember thinking
that earlier like after he couldn't get
the hammer out i was like he needs a
drink and uh and then he did so that was
great i also really just loved acting
like chris hemsworth and tom hiddleston
and oh my god the whole entire cast did
such a good job natalie portman always
makes
i feel like sometimes these sort of
scripts
can sound a little cheesy or a little
out there and i feel like she has a a
great way of being able to say her lines
in such a realistic way that she can
make a cheesy line sound good basically
so that's great kat dunnings i believe
is hers her name is is kind of the uh
the everyman in this movie of what we
would all react to as you know a regular
person in a situation like that again i
just think the whole cast did such a
great job so even though there's lots of
different types of movies kind of in one
i feel like they pulled it off
i think let me just also
the chemistry between chris hemsworth
and natalie
portman amazing i love that her name is
jane too because it kind of reminded me
of tarzan and jane he's just this big
guy from another world basically
and her name is jane i don't know if
that was done on purpose i don't know
when these comics came out i don't know
but um i just noticed that and thought
it was kind of funny
so again like i loved the ending too i
think it's a great setup for the
avengers
and i just feel like there weren't any
weak moments in this movie for me that i
could think of it was very fast paced
every scene felt like it was meant to be
in this movie also with endings it's
really hard to have a good ending
especially one where you're trying to
set up for another movie because it's
kind of like where do you go from here
but i thought overall this movie was
really enjoyable i now know why my mom
watch this movie all the time because
it's it's very entertaining so again
thank you guys so much for watching
subscribe if you enjoyed this video and
there are plenty of other videos on this
channel if you would like to check them
out by greg and john
they're great and give it a like thumbs
up same thing thank you guys for
watching this with me and uh i'm gonna
go get a horse
so
i'm gonna go to bed that's actually what
i'm gonna do
so thanks for watching and i'll see you
for the next movie stay tuned bye
[Music]